swing closely monitoring russia's
deployment in belarus which is the
biggest since
the end of the cold war
this is a dangerous moment for european
security
the number of russian forces is going up
the warning time for a possible attack
is going down
nato is not a threat to russia
but we must be prepared for the worst
while remaining strongly committed to
finding a political solution
the uk is playing a leading role
delivering both militarily and
diplomatically
i welcome your offer of more troops
ships and planes to nato
and additional troops that you are
deploying to poland showed allied
solidarity in action
the uk leads nato's bat group in estonia
you contribute to nato's air policing
and the aircraft carrier hms prince of
wales leads nato's maritime high
readiness force
all of this sends a clear message that
we will defend and protect all allies
we also have active diplomacy right
across the alliance with nato leaders
working to get russian russia to
de-escalate
i welcome your support to ukraine as
well as your recent contact with
president putin and the visit of foreign
secretary trust to moscow today
this morning i have sent a letter to
foreign minister lavrov
reiterating my invitation to russia
to continue our dialogue
in a series of meetings in the
nato-russia council to find a diplomatic
way forward
we are prepared to listen to russia's
concerns
and ready to discuss ways to uphold and
strengthen the fundamental principles of
european security that have
that we all have signed up to
we have proposed mutual briefings on
exercises and nuclear policies
ways to increase transparency and reduce
risks in military activities
reduce space and cyber threats
and a serious conversation on arms
control including nuclear weapons and
ground-based intermediate and
short-range missiles
these areas represent an agenda for
meaningful dialogue
but nato will not compromise on core
principles
the right
of each nation to choose his own path
and nato's ability to protect and defend
all allies
next week nato defense ministers will
assess options for further strengthening
allied
security this includes the possibility
of additional battlegroups in the
southeastern part of our alliance
renewed russian aggression will lead to
more nato presence not less
so prime minister thank you again for
the united kingdom's strong commitment
to our transatlantic alliance
and for your strong personal commitment
to nato so once again welcome yen sir
thank you very much for for welcoming us
today to to nato and great to see you
again out as ever when nato was founded
more than 75 years ago its members made
a commitment to collective security that
was unlike anything
in previous history
and when the berlin wall fell the people
of europe made clear that they wanted
their freedom and their security to be
inextricably tied together
and that's why
nato agreed that any country should be
free to pursue the security alliances
that it that country chose
and we must resist we must oppose any
return to the days when the fates of
nations are decided over their heads by
a handful of great powers
and i want to stress that this is not
just
about russia just as nato itself is not
just about russia of course not
this is about upholding the founding
principles of an alliance which perhaps
more than any other institution has
brought stability and peace prosperity
to the world and
that must be the bedrock of our
diplomatic efforts
the uk's commitment to european security
is unconditional
and immovable
we have the biggest defense budget in
europe and the second largest in nato
we've contributed more troops than any
other ally to nato's enhanced forward
presence
and today i've agreed with the secretary
general a package of support
to strengthen further our collective
security sending troops planes and ships
to defend nato from north to south
earlier this week i met the prime
minister of lithuania i'll be traveling
shortly to poland
and these are countries
where every day
the population wakes
with
an acute awareness
of the threat just
across their border
and they are countries whose voices and
views must be at the heart of every
discussion we have
because i believe that if we can keep a
strong grip
on the fundamentals those fundamental
principles that define
our alliance
and combine
strong deterrence with patient diplomacy
then we can find a way through this
crisis
but
the stakes
are very high
and this is a very
dangerous moment
and at stake
are the rules that protect every nation
every nation
big and small
thank you jens thank you all very much i
think we should probably have some
questions from the media i think i think
we're going to go to sorry
thank you
we'll go to sky news beth rigby
just a couple of questions prime
minister two weeks ago you said the
intelligence was particularly gloomy
when asked about the inevitability of a
russian invasion into ukraine since then
the combination of the threat of
sanctions deploying
troops to eastern allies diplomacy has
failed to de-escalate this situation
are you coming to the conclusion that
president putin actually wants this war
and to the secretary-general you just
said that this was a dangerous moment
for european security
different allies from france to the uk
to the us are taking slightly different
approaches to dealing with russia
are you concerned about these different
approaches sending mixed messages
to russia and are you worried that
differences between partners could
hinder any nato deployment thank you
thanks thanks very much beth look i i
think that this is
um to answer your question directly
about what i think is going on in moscow
and the calculations that are being made
there
i don't i honestly don't think a
decision has yet been taken but that
doesn't mean
that it is uh
impossible that something absolutely
disastrous could happen very soon indeed
and our intelligence i'm afraid to to to
say remains
grim and we're seeing the massing of of
huge numbers of uh of tactical battalion
groups uh potential groups on the on the
borders of of ukraine uh 70 or more this
is probably the most dangerous moment
i would say that in the course of the
next few days in what is the uh biggest
security crisis that uh europe has faced
for decades and we've got to get it
right and i think that the combination
of
uh sanctions and
uh
military resolve
plus diplomacy
is are what is in order and
everybody understands the
you you ask about whether uh where it
won across the west on sanctions i think
increasingly actually we are at one
and
i think that i i congratulate uh olaf
schultz uh of germany on the way he's
been able to move towards a tougher
position on on nordstream 2 difficult
though obviously that is uh for germany
and for for the german economy uh i
think that the uk has been able to help
to bring people together with a with an
automatic package of sanctions that
would hit uh
russian commercial
and strategic strategic commercial
interests
the tougher
those sanctions are the more automatic
they are the more chance we have of of
deterring what i think would be an
irrational response but what we're also
doing
is
ensuring that we have a
we engage
the russians attention we occupy their
bandwidth
and we get ready all over the eastern
frontier of nato and that's why uh jens
was kind enough to mention all the
things that uh that we're doing were
were supporting operation uh cold
response in uh up in the north in the in
the norway area with uh the prince of
hms prince of wales uh 16 air assault
brigade uh in estonia we're doubling the
uh the presence of tapa the enhanced
forward presence of tapa uh in poland
we're adding uh where i'll be going
shortly we're adding another 300 350
troops from four five commando were
doing air policing in romania uh
increasing the number of typhoons that
we're deploying out of uh out of cyprus
uh by a a squadron of typhoons and we're
sending ships to the eastern
mediterranean and the black sea and opv
and uh uh at a type uh 45. and that's uh
as i think uh
as against referred to we're also
putting on stand by a thousand troops uh
in preparation for a a humanitarian
crisis that may take place on nato's uh
eastern uh frontiers so
we're getting ready uh a military uh
we're making military preparations we're
getting ready economic sanctions
but we're also
willing to to talk and i think i think
yen summed it up uh very well in in what
he said uh you know there are some
things that are
non-negotiable
that's the idea of a europe whole and
free that's the idea that uh nato must
have an open door policy that the people
of ukraine must be able to aspire to
nato membership and then of course there
are things that it would be sensible to
talk about and things that uh nato and
the uk the us everybody is willing
certainly to to discuss and they include
transparency about nato exercises
about nato force posture
about the the
stationing of of missiles uh making
progress on certainly as as jen said on
the
the inf uh
area where where russia is in breach and
making progress on intermediate nuclear
uh missiles
all those
are subjects for discussion and far far
better to begin a discussion now uh than
to
uh
have a catastrophe so that's what that's
what we're pushing for and uh there's a
lot of
of effort going in on all those fronts
but beth you know whether it's going to
pay off now uh whether we're going to be
successful uh i simply can't say
then on the unity of the alliance i
think what we have seen over the last
weeks and months is actually a very
united nato where we stand together both
when it comes to
our diplomatic efforts but also when it
comes to the necessary military
adaptation we have uh implemented
on the diplomatic efforts all allies
agree that we need to
sit down with roshan to engage in good
faith in talks
to try to find a political peaceful
solution to the conflict and that's the
reason why um we have invited russia for
meetings in the format of the
nato-russia council why i welcome that
nato allies ask the united kingdom but
also other allies engaged directly with
russia secretary stresses in moscow
today
and other allies have reached out
because we need
a broad approach when it comes to
our diplomatic efforts
with uh with russia but this is based on
a unified message which all nato allies
has agreed we agreed
a comprehensive document which was sent
over to russia as uh as a very common
response of you as our united response
to the
legally binding
treaties that russia proposed for us
some weeks ago
and this is the agreed basis this is a
great message exactly as boris said
we list areas we're ready to sit and
discuss
on arms control missiles nuclear many
other issues
the point is it has to be verifiable and
balanced
and then we list also
some areas where we cannot make
compromises especially the right for
every nation to choose his own path and
the right of course for nato to defend
and protect uh all uh allies this idea
that that we should introduce some kind
of second-class allies those allies that
have joined nato after 1997
uh is absolutely not acceptable uh for
us
but but verifiable balanced arms control
that's something we absolutely are in
favor of and ready to engage in with uh
with uh with russia
um uh let me just briefly also add that
uh
the military uh adaptation
uh
sends a
signal
that that that russia has a choice they
can either choose a diplomatic solution
and we are ready to sit down but if they
choose confrontation they will pay a
higher price
there will be economic sanctions
there will be
uh increased
nato military presence in eastern part
of the alliance uk is really uh par an
important part of that all it announced
new deployments uh on top of what uh uk
has already
deployed in eastern part alliance
and of course the ukrainian army defense
force is much stronger now
than they were in 2014
because
they are better equipped better trained
a better command and
and i welcome that united kingdom and
other allies uh provide support to the
ukrainian uh defence forces uh so they
can defend themselves this is a
right for every nation to defend
themselves for self-defense and uh and
it's good that nato allies like the
united kingdom uh help ukraine to
to uphold that uh uh right we'll go to
laura spoke from bbc
um thank you very much um prime minister
how much further are you prepared to
commit the uk on top of what's already
happening would you for example in the
case of an invasion give uk military
support to some kind of insurgency and
if you're found to have broken the law
would you resign and can i ask you to
address this directly on behalf of
people at home it's not a hypothetical
question
there is a police investigation um and
secretary general russia is massing as
you said more than a hundred thousand
troops allies are like the uk committing
a thousand here and a thousand there but
is the scale of nato's attempt to
protect ukraine anything like a match
for what russia may be planning
yeah so so first of all i mean on your
on your on your point about uh what's
going on
at home uh laura that process must be uh
completed and i'm looking forward to it
being uh completed and and
that's the time to to say more on that
but
on your uh question about what we can do
uh to support ukraine further everybody
knows that the uk has been
you know
forward-leaning out in front in offering
support to to the ukrainian uh military
and uh yens is right in what he says uh
that the the ukrainian army is is now
very large probably two hundred thousand
uh probably 150 000 reservists and it's
my judgment i think it's certainly the
judgment of nato that they will fight
and they will resist very very strongly
and
they've been helped in uh in their
preparations for something as
catastrophic as as this with a lot of
training from the uk operation orbital
as you know has been going on since 2014
we trained 22 000 uh ukrainian uh
soldiers uh we're we're now in the last
uh two or three months we've sent uh
some uh some anti-tank weaponry the end
laws as you know two thousand of them
uh we will consider what uh more we can
uh we could conceivably offer but i have
to tell you uh that you know the
ukrainians are well
prepared there are things that uh we've
offered that they in fact don't seem to
to need because they think that they
have them uh in enough uh
uh
enough numbers already so
it's possible i don't want to rule this
out but
at the moment we think that the packages
is
is the right one
um but i i just want to to stress that
it would be an absolute disaster if it
were to come
to that and if uh there would be serious
bloodshed on ukrainian soil and i know
that people in russia must be thinking
about this too and i know that in the
kremlin
and across russia
they must be wondering whether it is
really sensible to expend the blood of
russian soldiers in a in a war
that i think is would be catastrophic
and also uh a pointless tragic and and
vastly economically costly to to russia
and
um
all i would say is that this is the
moment now to think of another way
forward and
president putin talks about the
indivisibility of security across the
european continent uh by which he means
that uh russia can't be threatened by
anything that nato does well look i want
to stress
nato is not a threatening uh
intimidating or aggressive alliance
that is not what nato does
nato has kept the peace in our continent
for so long and achieved so much by
being a defensive
alliance that's what nato does and i you
can't promote the
uh the indivisibility of peace in the
european uh land mass by by putting 130
000 troops on the borders
of of ukraine so
i think there's an opportunity
to
to talk to and to on all the subjects
that yens just described i think it's a
very good opportunity for us to put our
heads together and try to find ways of
reassuring
russia
without
compromising
those fundamental principles of nato's
open door policy i think there is a way
through
but it must also be accompanied
by a de-escalation
from russia
and
a withdrawal of the threats that we're
currently seeing so
i think it's time to de-escalate and to
talk
nato is a defensive alliance and our
purpose is to preserve peace to prevent
conflict and we do that by
standing together
as stating clearly as it is in china our
founding treaty that an attack on one
ally will trigger the response from the
whole alliance one for all all for one
and that's exactly what we're doing what
we're doing now uh at this very critical
time for european security
and the question was whether we are
doing enough well i think we understand
that we are doing many things at the
same time first of all we have already
increased the presence in eastern part
of the alliance
uh with more troops with the battle
groups uh also with
the the uk uh aircraft or carrier strike
group and also an american carrier group
and and more ships more planes the uh
increased presence in the eastern part
of the alliance
second we have increased the redness of
forces so we can quickly reinforce if
needed
this is nato response force but that has
been augmented by announcement from the
united kingdom from from the united
states from denmark from other countries
who have made it um
clear that they are ready to to to
assign more troops to the nato response
force so we can reinforce quickly um if
needed and we have increased the
readiness of these forces uh compared to
their normal readiness levels and
thirdly we are also now
looking into
whether we should have a more long-term
change in our posture in eastern part
alliance today we have battle groups in
the baltic countries and and poland um
the uk is leading the battlegroup in in
estonia but also increasing its presence
in poland but we are now also
considering to have
similar battlegroups for instance in the
black sea region in romania so
partly
all the increased presence partly
increased readiness so we can quickly
reinforce and also uh now looking into
more long-term changes in our uh posture
in eastern part of the alliance thank
you very much this concludes this press
conference thank you thank you thank you
thank you then boys we can do the last
uh
there you go well that concludes the
press conference between yo yen
stoltenberg the nato secretary general
and boris johnson uk prime minister i'll
summarize some of the key things that we
got from that press conference yellen
stoltenberg saying that russia would pay
a high price were they to go into the
ukraine on military terms uh he also
said that nato is to consider battle
groups in the southeastern territory of
nato boris johnson
meanwhile said that uh the uk would be
providing a a package of support to
further bolster security um in uh across
the nato alliance we go live now to
brussels and speak to skies ali forces
you uh ali while all that was going on
we're also getting some lines out of
moscow from uh liz trust who's been with
uh the russian foreign minister sergey
lavrov
that's right we're seeing a real
stepping up in the diplomacy liz trust
as you say in moscow again a show of
strength as you heard there from boris
johnson and jen stoltenberg at nato
boris johnson talking about his
unconditional
support for nato jens daltenberg saying
that nato's core principles will not be
compromised as you say he said that
russia will play a high price for
conflict and we're saying too that ben
wallace the defense secretary is going
to be in moscow tomorrow i thought what
was also interesting from that press
conference was the real sense of urgency
you got when it comes to the timing jen
stoltenberg saying that they have to
expect the worst and he said and i quote
that the warning time for an attack is
going up boris johnson said that he
doesn't think a decision has yet been
taken by russia but as he put it the
intelligence remains grim both sides
saying that they want to see that
diplomacy continuing and that diplomacy
working and as i say we've seen a real
world where not just from britain in
diplomacy but european leaders the
german chancellor has been in the u.s
the french president emmanuel macron was
in russia and in ukraine this week so
the diplomacy has stepped up but on that
core point of tension that central point
of tension around the expansion of nato
both sides are saying staying strong
it's hard to see where the gap for an
agreement will be without a creative
solution but both sides saying they want
to see that diplomacy continuing worth
saying too that boris johnson is going
to be in poland this afternoon where 350
more british troops have been sent over
the last few days and today he has also
confirmed that an extra 1 000 troops are
going to be made available to nato in
the event of a humanitarian crisis
thanks ali
well i'm afraid all that's uh rather
eaten into our program this morning so
we're not going to continue with uh
discussion of unilever's results now but
we're going to turn to another very
major ftse company and as economies
around the world reopen hopes are high
that exhibitions and trade fairs will
see a big revival this year will that be
good news for relics which before the
pandemic was putting on more than 400
events a year it's the 12th largest
company in the footsie 100 and also
provides data and analytics services to
professional and business customers
around the world and today it announced
a 13 rise in full year operating profits
on an adjusted basis to 2.2 billion
pounds well joining me now is nick luff
he is the chief financial officer at
relax nick morning to you thanks very
much for uh hanging on to speak to us i
mean looking at the results today
exhibitions is already bouncing back are
you fairly optimistic for the year ahead
you know it is i mean it gives us only
seven percent of the group's overall
revenue so it's not the key driver in
terms of the overall group results but
you've seen some very good numbers today
uh our risk business was up nine percent
of science and legal business is up
three percent and a 44 increase in
exhibitions as you say so uh recovering
strongly and we're looking forward to
strong growth in that business in 22 as
well
well let's take some of those uh other
parts of the business science technical
and medical that's the biggest single
division your operating profits are
actually slightly down there two percent
this year what was the story there
well that's only currency i mean it's a
international business dollar and dollar
revenue euro revenue if you look on an
underlying basis strip out the currency
movements profits are up three percent
uh in line with the revenue growth of
three percent
i mean one of the big things that uh
that business does is of course
published peer-reviewed scientific
research i presume there was a big
upsurge in that during the pandemic
there was we saw a very big step up in
submissions to our journals in 2020 and
through 21 the the elevated level of
submissions has been maintained
so um that's enabled that you know we've
our volumes have been going up we've
published more of those articles
and we're seeing very strong demand for
the information analytics we can provide
around the science that we're publishing
i'm amazed to see that uh getting on for
14 of that business is still print what
will that be this time next year
well it's been steadily declining over a
number of years i mean there are still
some customers who prefer the print
format